-Welcome back to
"The Tonight Show," everybody.
I'm Steve Higgins, and it's time
to play "Password"!
-"Password"! Oh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-All right,
let's meet our contestants.
To my left, she's starring
in the FX series
"Fleishman Is in Trouble,"
streaming now on Hulu.
It's Claire Danes.
-Claire Danes!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Claire,
your partner this evening
is the host
of NBC's "Tonight Show,"
Grammy Award-winning,
"New York Times"
best-selling author
[Laughing] Jimmy Fallon.
Wow.
-Oh, my God. Thank you.
Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's Grammy --
-Wow.
-Almost Grammy weekend.
I'm excited.
-Your first opponent
is a member
of the legendary Roots crew.
Say hello to Tariq Trotter!
-Alright.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I didn't know he was in a group.
-And his partner will be
at the Royal Rumble tomorrow,
streaming live on Peacock.
Give it up for Roman Reigns!
-Yeah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Good to see you, buddy.
Thanks for playing.
-Alright. The rules of the game
are very simple.
I will give each of you
a password,
then you'll give a one-word --
one-word clue only --
to get your partner
to guess the password.
The team with the most points
after four words wins.
Any questions?
-Well, I was just --
-All right. Never mind.
First clue -- Jimmy and Tariq.
-The password is...
-Red.
-[ Chuckles ]
[ Laughter ]
Um.
Is that all you got?
[ Laughter ]
-That's all he can give.
That's all he can give.
-Yeah, he actually gave --
-He mime-- he mimed.
-Ah!
-What did you say?
-Light.
-No.
-You said red?
-Red.
-I did. I did.
-He said..."Red."
-Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, he actually gave
a little mustard on it.
Red. Okay.
-Okay.
-Dijon called.
-Ready?
-Uh-huh.
-Five points.
-Mm-hmm.
-Dozen.
-Oh.
-Ohh.
[ Laughter ]
-Uh.
Eg-g-g-gs?
[ Laughter ]
-"Eg-g-g-gs"? How many
syllables are in "eggs"?
-I didn't see the red --
-Red?
-Red dozen.
-Red dozen?
-Tariq.
-Red dozen.
-Red dozen?
-Flowers.
-Oh!
[ Thumps table ]
-Roses.
-Ohh!
-What?!
-Oh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Laughs ]
-What are you talking about?!
Eggs!
-Red dozen.
[ Laughter ]
Claire and Roman.
-I mean, I'm pregnant.
-The password is...
-Red dozen.
-Claire, you're up first.
Eggs on the brain.
-Okay. Alright.
-[ Laughs ]
-Alright. Okay.
-It wasn't even eggs --
it was eg-g-g-gs.
It was like it was three words.
[ Laughter ]
-Alright.
-Okay. All right.
Oh, um...
[ Clicks tongue ]
[ Light laughter ]
Uhhh.
Uh. Costner.
-Nice.
-She stole mine.
[ Laughter ]
-"Yellowstone"?
-Yeah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-We got to go back...
-Whoa!
Whoa!
Zing zong ziggity
zing zong ziggy
zing zong ziggity zong.
-Okay. Okay, cool.
-Tariq, Jimmy,
the next clue is for you.
-"Yel-low-stone."
-The password is...
-Jimmy, you are going to
start us off this time.
-Alright, ready? We got this.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-One word, okay.
-Okay.
-One word.
-Mnh.
[ Light laughter ]
[ Laughter ]
Safety.
-Net.
-Oh, a good, good guess --
wrong though.
-Oh.
-But good.
[ Laughter ]
But it was good.
It's still good.
-Yeah.
-No, you can't mime it!
[ Indistinct shouting ]
-What is that?!
[ Buzzer ]
-[ Chuckling ] What?
-You can't mime!
-What in the red roses --
What in the red roses
are you thinking about doing?
-Oh, my God.
-Okay, okay.
-The whole room just turned.
-Okay, okay, okay.
-No, don't even act like,
"Okay."
You did this!
-We're tossing it out.
-You were putting on a helmet.
[ Laughter ]
That's insane.
Alright.
-Okay. Cool. Alright.
-Alright.
-Might as well just say
"helmet."
-Okay.
-Claire and Roman...
-Alright, here we go.
-...we're gonna
give you the last clue.
It's worth a billion points.
-Wait.
[ Laughter ]
-The password is...
-No, that was thrown away.
Roman,
why don't you start us off?
-Okay, great.
-Mm.
-Must be nice to cheat.
[ Laughter ]
-Wow!
-Okay.
Let's go back
to all the other times
we played "Password."
-No, no.
This is a brand-new game.
-Okay.
-Here we go.
[ Laughter ]
-Roman, looks like --
you look confident.
-There's just no way
to do this one.
One word?
-You got it.
You got it. You got it.
Trust me.
-Tariq has faith in you.
-Um...
[ Sighs ]
Long game here. We're gonna
go back and forth here.
-Mm-hmm, mm-hmm.
-Candy.
-If you guess this, now,
I swear to --
-I would be amazed.
Candy.
Do you want me
to make it easier for you?
-No, hey, no --
-Candy.
-There we go.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Yeah.
-Candy.
-Oh.
-Candy, candy.
-Chocolates.
-Chocolates. No.
[ Laughs ]
[ Light laughter ]
-Easter.
-Oh!
[ Light laughter ]
-Hm.
-[ Chuckles ]
[ Laughter ]
Jellybean?
-[ Laughing ] No!
-What are you talking about?!
-No! Boo, no, no, no.
-[ Laughs ]
No.
-No, no, no.
No, that's not good.
-That's fair.
-Yeah. No. No.
-Just incorrect.
-I think Roman's
going to win this one.
-It's fine.
-Just remember where we're at.
-Mm-hmm, mm-hmm, mm-hmm.
-Oh, gosh.
-[ Sighs ]
Chicken.
-Ooh.
[ Audience ohhs ]
[ Light laughter ]
-Chicken, candy, Easter.
-I mean, 'cause it
could be two things.
-Mm.
-Pick one of them.
-Ah.
[ Laughter ]
Cadbury Egg?
-Ohh!
[ Audience oohs ]
Ohh! So close.
-One word.
-Yeah, one word.
-Yeah.
-It's right there.
-Uh, uh.
Pastel.
I don't know.
[ Audience ohhs ]
-Oh.
-[ Laughs ]
[ Laughing ] What?
What in the --
What in the world?!
-Hold on. Pastel.
-Blew his brain up.
-Wait, pastel.
-Okay.
-Pastel. Chicken.
-I just thought
it was such a given.
-Yeah, it should be a given.
-Eggs.
-Sorry. I --
-I'm going to say eg-g-g-gs.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Alright.
-Okay, okay, okay.
-Okay.
-Roman, your turn.
-Ah!
-Roman's turn.
-No, it's not eg-g-g-gs.
-Eg-g-g-gs.
-It's not eg-g-g-g-g-g-gs.
-Easter.
Chicken.
-Come on, come on.
Pastel.
-You got this.
-Tariq's got this.
-Eg-g-g-gs!
-Roman, you got it.
Roman, you got it.
-This is just an opinion here,
right?
-Okay.
-Nasty.
-Ooh.
-Peeps.
-Yeah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, my God.
Tie game!
-Bang, bang, bang, bang, bang!
-Ah!
-Oh, it is a tie game.
-Oh, my God.
Alright, we'll give it to --
Come on.
Claire Danes, Roman Reigns,
Tariq Trotter.
[ Cheers and applause ]
We're talking to Claire
after the break.
Stick around, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]